by Emily Thornbury the shadow defense
secretary in a very good morning to you
miss thorn beer have you come on here to
tell us you're resigning from their
front bench no I'm not gonna resign from
the front bench I am I like Pat and I
respect that but I think he's wrong
I think vote I think we have got
ourselves into a position as a nation
where the brexit ears had a had a
meeting wanted to leave Europe but they
have no plan as to what will happen next
I think we had a Tory government that
allowed us to have a referendum with no
plan B I feel like we they have led the
country into a dark wood and they've
just abandoned us there and I think that
the the UK now needs some leadership I
think that it's incumbent on the
opposition to do that I think that it's
really important that our people are
looked after that any negotiations that
happen look after our people as well I
think that what happened in the the
referendum was that half of the country
felt that the current system does not
look after them you know they are not
getting what they ought to get out of
our country so whether that's housing
whether that's whether that's people or
you know competing for their jobs or
that's access to services and we need to
make and the tragedy is many of those
yet many of those things how good you
are as a party to deal with it what do
you say to your shadow cabinet
colleagues you've been sitting around
the table discussing policy discussing
the referendum with them well many of
them when we hear many more many of them
have resigned that we sat many more are
to go what do you say well I think the
first thing I would say is that I'm
quite surprised we had a shadow cabinet
meeting on Friday in which we discussed
at length the the referendum and we
didn't really hear any of this at the
sherry cabinet I'm an ad that Shadow
Cabinet I explained that I was not going
to be in a position to be able to launch
my defence review at this stage because
obviously the effect of brexit was such
that we would have to look again that
defense because it will obviously have a
big big impact on that but it was also
because I want to make sure that we have
as unified a party as possible and so I
mean you know yeah I can I can stand
here and say oh I can sit here and say
you actually don't and we can all see it
now you don't have a unified party you
don't even have
I would appeal to people within the
parliamentary Labour Party to think of
the country and to think of the
importance of a United Labour Party that
is the alternative sue the government
they would say and they've something
been on here saying well you know they
are thinking of the country and they are
thinking for the sake of the country
that you've got the wrong leader he's
not going to get elected and he's not
going to be able to offer effective
opposition but it thought isn't it
because you know there were sort of dire
warnings about what would happen with
the local council elections and yet with
the local council elections we got as
good if not better a result than we had
done during the last Parliament and we
won all the mayoral elections and
obviously you know in London with a
whopping great majority fantastic
results in Bristol and so all the doon
says at that stage were approved to be
brought he looked like a winner then to
you Jeremy Corbyn you think he could
take on Boris Johnson he doesn't have
the same style as me he doesn't have the
same style as a lot of politicians but
you know what I think that when Jeremy
suddenly has been criticized for this
but from a lot of people but he said you
know I give the European Union seven and
a half out of ten I think that he spoke
with an authenticity and a reality is
that they spoke for the British people
because there were a lot of British
people who voted for me who would only
give it a kiss maybe help I think the
remain camp mayor because I I think that
if that if if David Karen had stepped
aside a bit and allowed a bit more of a
labour voice to come forward it would
have engaged better with a majority of
the people and I thought tell us that Mr
Cameron's team begged Jeremy Corbyn to
to get involved with him and he refused
they didn't want it he didn't want to
share a platform with him because
because our approach to Europe is
different and our approach to Europe we
think spoke better and and more
straightforwardly to to our voters and
so therefore we did not and Jerry and
David Cameron have made this as a it was
all about him all about his fantastic
deal all about his leadership you know
all I'm gonna you know I can answer this
and let me say that and standing outside
number 10 if we had had a bit more of an
authentic labour voice speaking to our
voters I think that that might have
shifted things a bit and I'll tell you
what that means right when you're asking
me what kind of leader Jeremy Corbyn is
actually you know am I saying that
Jeremy Corbyn is a better leader than
David Cameron I think I probably am
as I say it's a different style you know
and it's not one that the Westminster
village is used to and it's not one that
I adopt but it is what so many of so
many of you front bench colleagues are
you horrified at what they're doing and
those that have the pen boys now on the
resignation letter are you saying stop
you're destabilizing a great leader
who's going to be our next Labour Prime
Minister I'm saying that it is now now
is not the time to further destabilize
the country I say that the markets are
tumbling the pound is going through the
floor who people are lost our country is
lost we do not at this stage at this
stage for the Labour Party to go through
into Nissan warfare we must raise our
eyes above our tummy buttons and look
Jamal come show the same what works here
it is that is best for up you've got to
be in power to make a difference yes
does mr. Corbin look like a winner let
me turn it differently is he the best
leader you could have Jeremy Corbyn is
the leader he is a good leader he has
had good election results you know and
and I first fit well let me think you
know I mean if I don't think that for
example Obama is available I mean there
are other people you know that one could
think of but Jeremy is the Lee and he
was elected with a 60% majority a year
ago less than a year ago 60% majority of
our membership and the membership if
there was an election tomorrow and of
course it will be for them to decide to
our next leader is they will they will
vote for him in increased numbers you
know that is the reality it is it is our
duty as the front bench to make him as
good leader as he can be and for us to
be a team if he decided to stand down
because he's got this this this vote of
no-confidence people voting with their
their feats of present company excepted
from the front bench of his party if he
decided to stand down would you persuade
him try to persuade him to reconsider
he's not going to stand out there's a
stupid question sorry
but it is a stupid question he's not
going to stand down you know he has been
elected less than a year ago on the
on a huge mandate the one electoral test
that he's had the straight electoral
test on the on the local elections he
did well you know we did well as a party
you know there has been we have now got
our country turned upside down and
inside out with no idea of where we're
going now we do not go on your
leadership challenge now so you think
you can win back those voters who in the
referendum campaign on that single issue
said no we don't want to to go with your
point of view later support as you said
and by and large there's a single simple
message saying we are so concerned about
immigration we are so concerned about
the number of people coming to this
country quite legally and putting so
much pressure on our public services and
Jeremy Corbyn is told them time and time
again it's good for you they are free to
come do you think that's a good policy I
just think so there's two things I want
to say the first is I think we have to
learn from the Scottish referendum
you know when the Scottish referendum
happened instead of us reaching out to
our labour voters after the Scottish
referendum we got involved in in all
sorts of fights in the Scottish Labour
Party and I think that that was wrong
and I think that you know looking back
on it a lot of people regret it and I
think you should learn okay so that's
number two in relation to immigration I
think that again in all of this fuss you
know how much have people heard the
speech that he made yesterday on where
we think the future ought to be for us
in the with our relationship with Europe
and he was again he'd said we must look
again at the aspect of immigration but
you don't think well I'm gonna rephrase
it that you're fundamentally out of
touch with huge sways of Labor
supporters who don't live in the
Metropolitan bubble I think that there
are people wherever they live who feel
that they are left behind I think that
there are people on the day of the
referendum to a guy who said you know
I'm thinking of voting out assembly
because I've got two grown-up sons and
they can't get anywhere to live and I
think there's either too many people in
this country or we're not building
enough houses I think Jeremy forward
does go would you show serve under a
new leader if asked I will always do
what I think is best for the Labour
Party I believe that the Labour Party is
the best party to be in government and I
will always put all my all my efforts
into ensuring that we get the best
labour government that we can shadow
defense secretary thank you very much
indeed Emily Thornberry there